[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui votre chiot endommagés pas de tour
de magie malheureusement allé yacast
hakim a appelé la merde c'est pour le
port de vannes excellence brut alors oui
bien sûr tout à l'heure je vais vous
montrer des images extraordinaires que
personne n'a relevé qui concerne un très
grand humoriste d'aller voir dans
quelques instants alors en attendant
c'est avec le mardi c'est le jour du
zumba fr mardi alors syrie dans la
grande barque à samedi magloire vous a
appris qu'il avait un tatouage away et
vous mène entendu parce que vous êtes un
désormais un journalisme d'investigation
alors j'ai voulu savoir où se trouvait
ce tatouage et viendront vous les placez
vous avez vite regretter d'avoir posé la
question
savourez ce magnifique zumba bas
[Musique]
qui a des tatouages magloire fait un
tatouage ben oui t'as quoi t'as quoi un
tableau de modigliani des sources co2
très sérieux il est tatoué au plateau
quand tu es vous il est déjà trop tard
[Applaudissements]
magloire que j'embrassais bien entendu
magloire
il est marrant c'est vrai très heureux
qu'on le revoit la télé bien sûr ce
magnifique et cette fois ce qu'il a fait
toutes ces années c'est vrai c'est
dingue quand quelqu'un comme ça
disparaît au ventre pendant 20 ans de
l'antenne mois il était avec moi sur le
morning man ray petit cassé mais je sais
exactement c'est le seul mec qui venait
directement de boîte de nuit à ce rigolo
et magloire alors là maintenant ça va
mieux mais à l'époque je lui dit à son
frère il te parler le matin il faisait
une chronique j'étais animateur d une
chronique concerne il te parler mon
frère il y avait un minibar dans sa
bouche c'était un truc glauque mon frère
tu voyais les bouteilles déjà bull et
jean ricoux je te jure c'est un truc de
malade
badr ici c'est calme et bataille bois
plus c'est calme et il voit plus mais
c'est calme et que de ce côté là les
gens chez nous va bien sûr en selle
alors la semaine dernière en plein
pendant ma chronique vous avez une
nouvelle figure ans et une fulgurance
qui touche au génie tiendra ce que vous
apercevez devant vous une boîte de
mouchoirs en papier well as souvient
qu'à expliquer ce qui se passe vous
décidez de vous lancer un défi vider la
boîte de mouchoirs en moins de 30
secondes balles je rappelle juste quand
même que personne nous aurait demandé
aussi tout seul vous êtes chauffé tout
seul vous êtes le seul gars qui se
lancent des défis tout seul et pas des
défis comme arrivée au sommet de
l'himalaya ou faire le marathon murs non
vie d un paquet de mouchoirs en 30
secondes alors que touax et autres jeux
olympiques l'ajustement j'espère que ces
disciplines sera en jeu moi je te lis et
vous soirée le porte drapeau wade de
franc et que vous regardez moi ça 6 en
30 secondes
j'arrive à enlever tous les mouchoirs
ouais je veux gagner un deuxième repas à
tout public
quoi e
[Applaudissements]
quand vous êtes à fond vous ne
supporterez pas un si grand d'échec dans
votre carrière
et quand vous sortez vernet votre langue
c'est que plus rien d'autre n'existe pas
mais oui à l'origine on vient de voir
une performance sportive digne des 9
secondes 58 du cndd bolt ou l'anneau
marie josé perec dans ma singer est ce
que je remarque qu'à chaque fois c'est
aux célébrations de victoire
franchement n'importe quel jeu vous êtes
le seul gars qui peut faire un tour
d'honneur parce qu'il a fait mot compte
triple au scrabble c'est fou alors ce
soir j'ai voulu rendre hommage non pas à
cyril hanouna l'animateur mais le
sportif surtout à toutes ces
célébrations modeste sur les choux
fleurs et des joutes et de bouteilles
beaugrard du batman s'élèveront ces
célébrations
[Applaudissements]
puis vous avez la victoire modeste séry
d'ailleurs la prochaine fois que vous
remportera un chiffon mais vous ferez
votre victoire sans vraiment comme ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
mais c'est vrai c'est vrai que je suis
un supporter a battu assez fou n'importe
comment à n'importe quel jeu j'aimerais
bien voir un jour la tête qui fait qu'on
y perd malheureusement on sait si vous
offert un cadeau aujourd'hui non bah ça
va arriver juste après la plus loin je
le fais un petit fric jean-michel j'ai
envie de vous offrir un cadeau puisque
vous le méritez
j'avais déjà ce film je veux bien
deuxième cadeau à l'horaire c'est vrai
sophie je suis moi non mais ça va je
peux assumer j'ai l'impression qu'ils
commencent déjà vous saouler en tout cas
vous êtes très jolie est juste la cerise
de groupama qui ont atterri ce qui est
arrivé à un grand timoré sur ce plateau
et il est toujours pas remis je pense à
c'est vrai on verra ça dans un instant
nature fou de sciences moi je dis que
j'ai fait un bac scientifique menteur
bien sûr 20 heures c'est moi non basile
deux mois un un élément chimique je veux
dire ce que c'est allez h2o très bonne
saison démarre doucement redémarre
doucement à nouveau deux comme ça
témoigne jean lev lourié sur les blu ray
bon allez vas-y normal chimie du benzène
le benzène frérot cbn le choco bn le
benzène c'est pas bn juste pour le
plaisir
deux autres
le faux score c'est pas moi c'est vrai
c'est au jeu il faut une transition
alors écoute c'est quoi leur scène ses 6
h 6 bat tout le monde le sait mais pas
telle qu'on la question frère non je te
parle du tableau de mendeleïev
périodique des éléments quoi aller
barcelone parce que vous allez parler sa
mère alors dites-moi quand il est arrivé
chez nous alors on me fait le tableau
périodique des éléments pour les jeunes
qu'ils en gardent bien sûr vous me
donner par exemple sais pas vous mais
des palombes le calcium
je vous dit lequel seul le symbole cca
et louis lamarque ces voix-là alesi donc
donnez-moi l'uranium le royaume uni au
gras savoye l'avenir quand même
et croyez-moi savez pas vous même si
celle ci eut tout simplement pu mais il
est fier en plus mais c'est le potassium
sepa cas par cas si quelqu'un sait
kellogg's quoi le carbone c'est tout
simplement c'est quoi non le carbone ccc
ccc l'adn l'azoté exactement et le
sodium ena enn à ciel de celle du sel le
formule du sel oui tendue du sel frère
ou japonais h2p deux ans
c'est comme quand même où celle c'est
quoi avoir une salle la formule 17 c'est
bien c'est d'un côté c'est elle d'autres
cela n'a donc n 1 s'il a fait le
chlorure de sodium est plus connu sous
le nom de chlorure de méthyle fallait
démontrer et quand on le met à la
lumière sa fin précipitée blanc on va
s'occuper des bogdanoff beaucoup mais
pour l'instant on va s'occuper de cette
personne est ce que vous la connaissez
ces séries bien sûr nous fait une
rubrique tous les soirs malanville est
arrivé au départ et je veux dire très
peu de gens y croyaient et puis de fil
en aiguille ça a pris ça a pris une
ampleur dans mes sont les connaissent un
monde de fous pas c'est le bon il est
bon il est excellent et tous les gens me
disent 6 rc aujourd'hui c'est la
révélation de l'année
rome s'est exclamé je vous dirai enfin
bref je vais faire très attention
vous savez déjà appelé par d'autres
chaînes wii t1 qui idf1 idf à savoir les
aime beaucoup et c'est vrai que écoutez
si vous pouvez faire les deux c'est
l'autre c'est parti alors dans
l'animation télé y aura un avant et un
après cyril hamelin et jean pierre
pernaut c'est le seul présentateur de jt
qui n'a pas de prompteur
cyril hanouna c'est le seul présentateur
télé qui n'a pas de pantalon oui parce
que hier vous avez décidé
ouais de faire honneur à la journée son
pantalon et c'est vrai que ça émoustille
et tous ceux qui étaient devant leur
télé on pas moi personnellement je m'en
foutais un petit peu mais vous attribue
ont fait beaucoup parler et moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est quand même qu'on a le
futur président de tunisie qui anime son
émission en slip et comme on est hantée
pmp plus personne est étonné regardez
mon sens c'est très sympa mais beauté ça
y est on est de retour c'est lundi les
cherry hill on va jouer dans un instant
a déroulé ses et les hauts fourneaux
[Musique]
forcément la plus grande marque de slip
du monde immédiatement contacté
m
[Musique]
je suis papa
c'est bien
le tunisien de bim le confort de la
merguez et l'autriche et des pois
chiches
c'est ce que j'ai vu il paraît que c'est
le confort de la merguez et des pois
chiches votre merci ouais c'est bien
cette fois çi exactement ça faisait
longtemps
ça vous amène aller moi je trouve
j'avais des jambes splendide vous savez
que personnellement ma mais les jambes
sont splendides
ah oui bah merci pour le risque et
accessible tout est accessible pour vous
je vous le dis le tout doit disparaître
je suis en liquidation totale pour vous
oui madame
c'est vrai que moi je regrette d'avoir
commencé aujourd'hui et pas hier du coup
ah oui alors vous allez voir jean-michel
on chip
alors là c'est phénoménal est phénoménal
il a des gens magnifiques non mais le
mollet est incroyable la legal team
lèvent
si c'est bon c'est bon merci non mais
c'est aimer ou jean michel thomas pour
frais d'émission slip qui n'ont demandé
ça valait boga mais oui j'ai mérité ce
qui alors justement la tension qui
seront tous - est-ce que les bold as met
en slip se voit toujours habillé moi non
mais c'est parce que j'ai une
fascination pour eux et je vois pas les
beaux gars tranquille chez jean poulit
tu pourras qua non est ce qui vous
arrive de vous baladant slip à la maison
tous un nom mais d'abord on dort pas tu
sais danser le nom des gens
ça fait combien d'années ce n'est pas
dans mes écouteurs comment cet enjeu non
sans rigoler je dormais pas du tout non
d'or un peuple entre une heure et deux
heures par nuit sans rigoler ça soit tu
te monde
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais la réponse est oui
ibos ne pourrait pas comprendre dit leur
oui bah oui parce qu'il bosse énormément
c'est vrai vous écrivez ou fait la loi
non mais c'est vrai que m cette année
c'est haro s'il faut pas oublier mais
vous bossez beaucoup vous arriver à
dormir qu'une heures par nuit et en
forme non mais c'est une question
d'habitude en fait comment fameuse micro
sieste ça existe en fait tu dors entre
une minute et et et trois minutes tu es
un vrai sommeil etc et réparateurs et
qui suffit si on peut dire à se
reconfigurer pour la journée entière
c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas besoin de
dormir 8 10 heures quelquefois on a des
dormeurs qui dépasse les 12 heures ce
qui est incroyable c'est quand même la
moitié de la vie qui est perdu dans la
structure voilà la vie si on est là en
plus il ya une étude statistique qui
vient de montrer enfin cédé aux états
unis sur 210 mille personnes ce qui est
quand même pas mal que lorsqu'on dort
plus de huit heures
en fait le risque d'avc est augmenté de
40% a donc essayé de nous
moi j'adore moi je dors très peu mais
moi je vous dit combien je vais dormir
dormir cinq six heures alors faudrait
dormir combien 4 4 entre 4 et 4 contres
c'est pourquoi je te sors les coachs
sportifs quand il coache les
footballeurs professionnels ils disent
faut dormir 9 10 heures mais si moi je
dors je demande en mai on vole en éclats
et c'est sûr mais à regarder eux ça fait
ça fait combien d'années que dans leurs
40 ans ouais enfin tu peux 50 ans qui
dort muller comment garder il performe
[Applaudissements]
il pète la forme ils sont enfouis et tu
les a déjà vus pantoufles à ton frère
géant fraîcheur de vivre hollywood
chewing gum frère à tfo non ça je le
crois moi je dors deux temps de 2h 2h30
par nuit ah ouais ça me dit quand je
dors davantage de violentes migraines je
n'en sais rien vous voyez vous allez sur
la santé vos folies pour savoir plus
santé non mais c'est vrai vous avez de
violentes migraines
ouais dès que je dors plus de 4,5 heures
fera habitués on va très bien active
lors donc les bogdanoff voilà on le dit
on peut dormir une heure par nis et être
enfin bien sûr voilà on n'a pas la
réponse pour le slip ce matin est ce que
vous êtes déjà et ce combat parce que
est ce que vous mettez des fois en style
lors devant la télé tranquille il a
regardé parce que on a un peu vous êtes
toujours en recherche de voix de du
cumul du big bang
c'est vraiment ça ouais mais là on a un
nous amis qui est quelqu'un d'assez
extraordinaire qui se met effectivement
en fagne puissance en toi oui on pas une
terre comme un café qui serait le
conflit jusqu'à jean mich est d'accord
est en fête son but c'est de se mettre
sur un tapis de glace ce n'est donc de
la glace et de rester comme ça au moins
une
c'est ce qui fait la plupart du temps en
méditation et il y arrive et il est
aujourd'hui et vous arrêter en si bon
nous oui ils se renvoient la balle
bien sûr
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que je n'étais jamais en slip non
mais on peut paraît pas là je sais pas
ce que la question n'est pas anodine
je sais je sais que c'est autour du rire
du tout mais joli c'est vrai qu'ils font
plein d'émissions ils ont des réponses à
tout tout le temps ils ont fait des
descentes le plateau il arrive ça ne la
mettons cet ensemble d'accords parce que
c'est pas une anodin je sais que voilà
ils sont ils tombent sont toujours tu
dois trois quarts des recherches
scientifiques en slip la voilà qu'ils
arrivent à la maison et je mets ton
blues c'est sympa ou en combinaison des
combinaisons voilà l'exemple on était
sur un coût d'environ 100 membres actifs
sur les superposer sur mamy c'est vrai
je vous fais tout à manger jouer des
trucs t'inquiète pas condamner ce type
du coup on était tous dans votre slip
série puisqu'ils nouvelle fois vous avez
lancé nouvelle mode en télé parce
qu'après la mode veille le team pantalon
de jogging vous lancer la mode donc
veste de costume boxer et comme
d'habitude les plus grandes stars télé
ont décidé de s'inspirer de vous et
présentent donc leurs émissions à votre
tenue je me suis procuré les images en
avant-première
atteint
dans l'invité fait partie de nos vies
depuis longtemps c'est vrai que depuis
les ch'tis
il est devenu un acteur majeur de ce
métier qui causa la méditerranée dont
grâce à vous il peut enfin animé comme
il est en vacances à thessalonique
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue contente de retrouver
pour un nouveau numéro de 50 et les
cancers de l'actuel et même le plus
grand scientifique du monde des idoles
de kelly b2b lee présente désormais son
émission en slip c'est impressionnant
bonsoir
qu'est ce qui fait que les ongles
souvenirs d'amours précis de notre
petite enfance essayez de vous rappeler
de votre vieux souvenir
et oui il reste une petite chose encore
il ya pourtant michel mr c'est vrai que
c'est chaque jour une meuf différentes
pour vous syrie c'est chaque jour une
émission différentes
touche pas à mon poste ballon ce temps
pose la grosse rigolade la grande marque
haslam en une semaine vous fait non
c'est pas vous slam danse pas moi c'est
presque une semaine fait plus d'antenne
que michel cymes en trois ans alors
forcément bon moment que ça n'est plus
dans quelle émission vous fc ce qui
s'est passé jeudi 13 ans des faits
graves on ne vous a pas fait gaffe on
est dedans pendant ce temps poste nous
avons un petit peu confondu
on va se retrouver dans un instant pour
la deuxième partie notre invité de la
semaine
garcia belattar ya un monde post dedans
ça peut prêter à confusion
voilà quoi on comprend alors justement
pour finir revenons-en à une de vos
mains trois missions quotidiennes
la grosse rigolade désormais chaque
vendredi sur ses vitres alors là la
prochaine va être complètement folle
ouais je vous le dis déjà celle de la
semaine des vols la voilà la pleut on a
pleuré de rien
vincent moscato michel boujenah laurent
baffie bas il ya bien sûr has qui sera
la liane foly il ya trente gastambide
hakim djemilli il ya du rythme car ici
titoff
ouais on attendait du très bon travail
avec les choix aussi que qu'était la
semaine a été très mal mais qui est un
peu passée inaperçue puisque quelque
chose qui vous a étonné pendant
l'émission ou pas rien du tout on est ok
ça concerne gad elmaleh en fait des
lilas qui fait l'émission on va dire que
c'est un pudique il va jamais faire de
vannes sexuelle ça le gêne
sauf qu'en face de lui la vie laurent
baffie et cette place là et demande à
laurent baffie de faire une blague sans
qu'elle soit sexuelle c'est comme
demander à valérie baning d'envoyer un
texto c'est impossible
alors vous allez voir la tête de gad à
chaque mots crus de laurent baffie c'est
extraordinaire comme il est mal à l'aise
lorsque j'ai fait un petit résumé des
éléments de la soirée de gad
ils se demandent déjà pourquoi c'est lui
qui est tombé sur le déguisement de
jeunes est de former rises est
magnifique ogre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
participer à un tour de magie incroyable
de philippe lachaux bien de wight
rectorie c'est un peu ça fait vraiment
alice a maintenant tu vas me répéter
trois fois de suite jean tatata la
couleur en bas à droite manille une
trois fois de suite
dring dring dring à l'eau est donc
surtout gad adore laurent baffie mais
dumont rencontre achevée sa tête je
crois qu'ils tirent pas du tout et si je
bouffe bien le cul et si tu l'as fait
jouir mais tu ne rend aucun reproche
donc c'est un gorille travail tous les
matins et se tapent sur le torse effet
je suis le gorille ont pu leur et tous
les jours ils enclins à nîmes
[Musique]
et le quatuor non non non merde en plein
dans la chatte si vous commandez dit
whisky c'est que vous devez c'était
quelque chose et le jeune fille oui
aujourd'hui c'était ma première pipe
[Musique]
lolo qui serait pas sur cette semaine et
gâteaux j'embrasse très très fort merci
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]